the medicinal value of it when I need is  to make a bomb so I can put it on my  sore muscles and joints I had a  tremendous amount of surgeries and work  done and I'm in my mid-50s living in a  very brutally cold climate this is  hopefully gonna keep me limber enough to  keep my lifestyle going pour it in here  then I'm gonna take oil all of the  resins those little clippings have I  want to leech it out into the oil I can  use it as a oil treatment but I prefer a  salve a cream this is my beeswax there  we go now you can see that nice amber  color this is the salve that I'm after  right there you see the scar line you  know it hurts like hell through here but  this is gonna help me sleep and get me  through this and get me through it with  a smile instead of a tear